we're going to do a few things today to
close off all the new concepts in
parametric's which are very happy about
by the way I mean we're ahead of time we
should be ahead of time but we're really
ahead of time so you guys have done very
well we all were lacking really and
you'll do this in period 2 a little bit
and on Friday to is I'm just in time to
take these IDs so we're gonna put them
all on one page so you can see them all
at once and just just use them in a
variety of different contexts and
sometimes in combination with each other
ok so that's all we're missing from this
topic and then it's done our next topic
this is the HSC topic and it's going to
be called series of sequences ok I've
alluded to it before we're going to deal
with it in depth next term ok but apart
from that we also need to settle stuff
about that slots for the extension to
classes next term so you please remind
me after this happens to have that
conversation with you because I can
always guarantee I'll forget because
obvious Oh caught up in the awesomeness
of evidence so I need a new color let's
have a go by the way I just recommend
and most of you guys are pretty good at
this already because that's how you got
to this place in year 11 I always hear
you whenever you get through a topic
right you do this kind of 8 you've
produced for yourself alright this is
kind of like for lack of a better way to
say it this is my cheat sheet this is my
review this is my summary of all the big
concepts and ideas that I can look at
one glance see you know week's worth
sort of games here right and also gives
you a reference point for when you come
back to this a few weeks months later
and you're looking like recognize this
recognizes know this because you're
learning so very much all at once right
so that gives you a pointer say oh this
is what I need to revise ok and having
it all in one point makes that process
much easier right so let's think about
this parabola x squared equals 4 y let's
think about all the things that we all
the results that we have shown so far
well we think parametrically first
because that's kind of a big point of
this topping every point on the parabola
can be thought of in terms of the
parabola just like every point like a
unit circle can be thought of in terms
of theta its cos theta sine theta right
every point of the parabola its
coordinates can be given by two AP AP
squared or 288 e squared or whatever
maybe you want to give that parameter
for this let's just go with P that'll do
okay
if you have a second point that will
most likely be called Q and its
coordinates will be 2 AQ AQ squared so
when you've got a tangent I wonder if
you were this one yeah y equals this is
one of the simplest results okay because
the tangent it's going to have that same
gradient right so you go P X and then
you take away
yeah a B squared right so there are a
lot of similarities for this from what
you're right now just by defining a
point okay
the normal was not nearly as elegant and
as a result its form wasn't particularly
pretty but you're gonna get this to AP
AP cubed yeah you seen this before the
dog walls and we're gonna get to the
Cartesian one as well which we didn't
get to look at yesterday the normals
don't come up as frequently as the
tangents because you could do with
interesting things with the tangents but
it's to earth will get that and having a
bit of a memory of it alright let's go
to the chord now you remember the chord
right is what happens to the tangent
where doesn't intersect at one spot when
it intersects at a pair right so that's
why this equation and this equation are
so very similar to each other I'll give
you a clue it starts with a half-pay
plus Q very good it's the average the
gradient or is the average of the
gradients at the two taejun's on your
endpoints right so that's that minus a P
Q okay
these can all at limit of this as q a
purchase P right where this becomes P R
you get 1/2 times 2 P P everyone
okay so one of two things will happen
with all the either number one exactly
what you said you have to prove all of
these and then take too long they'll
often guide you through that process
like part 1 will be the tangent is etc
right it's like and I was believers
before it's not like a result like this
wait but prove it
but now you've proven it you never need
to prove it again but Paris is not the
same okay
that's option 1 you've got to prove it
option 2 is they will actually in the
question they will say the equation
other normal is X plus P y equals down
and up and in big bold italic letters
they'll say do not prove this do not
prove it and then they'll be expecting
you like what they are sitting there for
is can you use it in the context of this
question and we don't want students to
get caught up in groups I proved it
wrong and then I can't do the rest of
the question and I've lost 4 marks
automatically so you'll see one of those
and it'll make it pretty clear okay
let's keep going there's a couple of
things I wanted to note about the chord
right if it's a focal chord right if the
chord passes through the focus what do
we know about P and Q they have a
special relationship yeah that's right
those those teachers are going to be
perpendicular which means that their
gradient speed Q they multiply to
negative 1 right if it's a focal chord
that is true another figure about chords
is that there's a particular focal chord
that goes straight across the parabola
at least if you've got a normal you know
up oriented one right so you've got a
particular focal chord here's a more
specific way to say it that is parallel
to the directrix right so I've got the
directrix hanging out down here and the
latus rectum is going to be parallel to
that right what's special about the
light attractor what makes it the focal
chord this special focal point yeah
the length of it the length of it we
might wanna the length is for a okay its
gradient the gradient of the latus
rectum in this case would be zero okay
but if Y if my problem in this way right
it wouldn't have a grady because the
latus rectum would be vertical okay so
it's parallel to the directrix okay now
I just want to point out one more quick
thing
don't don't mix it in with what you're
about to write yeah because I will make
this nice and neat but just on the side
I want you to know something here's a
simple parabola okay if I draw the
directrix yeah my choice really likes
I'm gonna have to get rid totally
there's the directrix here is where the
latus rectum could be straight across
okay now because probably symmetrical
shapes right do you notice what we about
the gradients of these endpoints right
here and here okay what could about the
grating of the tape great the tip here
what kind of relationship do they have
yeah
they are reflections of each other right
in fact because you're if some has a
gradient of P right actually that's a
bad example I'll make this one P because
it's increasing okay it's going up at
that right because the exact refer the
grip mine is right but hold on a second
we just said the latus rectum is a
special it's a special focal chord and
has to pass through the focus right so
if this is P and this is Q like Q is
negative P right then this should still
be true right pink you should still be
negative 1 and this should be true ah
but but if P times Q but you just told
me is negative P if they're equal to
negative 1 you're following with me ok
I've got minus P squared equals minus 1
so P squared equals 1 did I do
everything right is that look okay now
in this particular example I just kind
of define for P to be positive right P
could be either one you're just gonna
flip it around like you have P here and
Q there or vice versa okay but what this
means is that the lattice rectum
these points across here they're always
not only does it have this property that
it's parallel right but the gradients
will always exactly be one that's
interesting did you ever notice that
probably not because we don't tend to
draw our parabola to scale right so in
all the fatter or thinner than what it
actually is but go ahead I uh I know
some of you're gonna do this anyway go
into desmos right pull up do any
parabola you like right this is just for
any parabola you can make the focal
length with a really really small or
really really tall when you plot in the
lattice rectum right and it's not it
what's the equation of this by the way
4x squared equals 4 oh wow what's the
equation of this remember the equation
of this guy the directrix is y equals
minus hey this is gonna be y equals a
right this is very easy to put onto onto
desmos right put that across and then
plot the pages right you will find them
intersect at exactly 45 degrees because
of this point okay
because its value rather all right now
it was just interesting that's pretty
much all that we know in terms of
results for the parametric
representation of a problem okay